Газ для Німеччини - свого роду наркотик:
опалення працює на газі, струм генерується з газу,
промисловість працює на газі.
Торік більше половини газу німці отримували з Росії.
Тепер через війну в Україні Берлін хоче відмовитися
від газу з РФ. Але для цього тут недостатньо розвинена інфраструктура.
Який у Німеччини план?
Питання в тому, скільки нам ще потрібно досягти?
За даними брюссельського дослідницького центру Bruegel,
наразі у Німеччини дефіцит газу становить близько
30 відсотків. І ще багато чого можна зробити в цьому напрямку.
Тож це виглядає досить добре:
адже в цей розрахунок ще не взято
плавучих терміналів з прийому зрідженого газу,
які з'являться до кінця року.
За рахунок одного такого терміналу
можна скоротити розрив ще на 5%.
І ще не враховано в цій аналітиці те,
що виробництво електроенергії на газі має припинитися.
Його замінять бурим вугіллям, можливо, навіть струмом
з атомних електростанцій.
Тобто ми маємо ще кілька козирів у запасі.
А далі на черзі домогосподарства:
кожен градус опалення у домівках
також суттєво зменшує потребу в газі.
Тож варіанти є. Зима буде не з кращих,
але це потрібно вирішити раз і назавжди.
Зниження температури у квартирі лише на один градус
економить енергію на 7%, ідеться у дослідженні Greenpeace.
Ще один захід - економити електрику.
15% електроенергії у Німеччині виробляється
за допомогою газу.
Це саме ті заходи, які є важливими вже зараз.
І ви можете бачити, що ціновий механізм явно працює.
До речі, це можна підтвердити статистикою.
Ми спостерігаємо, що споживання газу
вже тепер скоротилося на 6% порівняно
з аналогічним періодом минулого року
при зростанні цін на газ на 50%.
І цей показник далі зростатиме.
Багато споживачів у Німеччині готові інвестувати
у безгазові технології. Приміром, разюче зріс
попит на каміни та дров'яні печі.
На них черга на місяці наперед.
Дедалі більше людей купують сонячні батареї.
Вони з'являються навіть у приватних будинках - на балконах.
Кароліна родом із України.
Вона заснувала в Берліні стартап,
який займається продажем таких балконних сонячних модулів.
Від початку війни ми мали величезний попит,
звісно, через зростання цін на енергоносії.
І я гадаю, люди розуміють, що вони повинні
також відіграти свою роль в енергетичному переході.
Ці сонячні батареї можуть забезпечувати
від десяти до 20 відсотків приватної електроенергії -
з балкона, що виходить на південь.
Гадаю, що справа не лише у сонячній енергії.
Я вважаю, що нам потрібно набагато більше
відновлюваних джерел енергії. Теплові насоси,
сонячні модулі та інше.
Це допоможе не лише переходу на зелену енергетику,
але й зменшенню наших рахунків за електрику.
Приміром, на ринку вже є водонагрівачі,
що працюють від сонячної енергії.
Це ж так чудово! Так працює ринкова економіка
через ціновий механізм.
Політики вже давно мали дати сигнал ринку.
Так влаштована ринкова економіка, що коли ціни
надсилають відповідні сигнали,
тоді учасники ринку стають активними.
Це сприяє новим, хай навіть невеликим винаходам,
які можуть вирішити проблеми.
Але що робити тим, хто з фінансових причин
не може собі дозволити ці винаходи?
Необхідно переконатися, щоб для найбідніших
домогосподарств, з рівнем доходів нижче середнього,
було політичне рішення про ту чи іншу форму компенсації,
залежно від зростання цін,
такий собі газовий бонус.
Німеччина нині має гроші, щоб відмовитися
від газу з Росії і при цьому підтримати бідних.
Це буде важко.
Але ми робимо спільні зусилля
зі стратегічних міркувань для свободи та миру
в Європі, і стаємо дедалі менш залежними від путінського газу
швидше, ніж планувалося раніше.
Тим більше, що це і так необхідно прискорити
заради захисту клімату.
І я думаю, що політики мають нині добрі шанси,
аби населення підтримало такий перехід.
Тож, німці крокують маленькими кроками
до великої мети - повної відмови від газу з Росії.